how are you doing sir
i'm great and i see battle of the
planets uh gotcha man and back at you
man
hearts i'll tell you i've been waiting
for them to do some sort of movie with
these characters
yeah it's so good i just don't get it
yep
it's so oh my one of my favorites oh my
gosh
yeah by the way maybe this will help get
things made as more people
you know maybe so yes really good ib
um so a bunch of questions for you um
the first being i'm sure there was many
different ways you could put tom and
jerry on screen
the different from the cartoon version
to like a more
photorealistic one could you sort of
talk about how you guys
settled on the way tom and jerry were
going to look in the film and it was
ever radically different
yeah no one of my big inspirations was
who framed roger rabbit
and what i loved about um that hybrid
world is that
they they always just were specific to
the two rules that these two universes
have you know on one that one being
animated
one being real and when i thought about
um tom and jerry and how they should be
represented on screen
you know you can look at you know some
have taken animated 3d or
try it in some way to make uh make the
characters real
and we we just always wanted to you know
um if you're going to bring these
characters back to life
why not make sure they look like what
you remember you know that every
generation especially those
older generations who um grew up on this
see something that they recognize and
there and there doesn't have to be any
moment of
uh you trying to figure out okay does
this look like time we tried as best
possible
you know knowing that most of these
original artists aren't with us anymore
we tried as much as we could to make it
look just like the original characters
and um hopefully the the true fans of
this uh cartoon
enjoy that i laughed a lot when i saw
the tim burton batman joke
in the movie uh did you call tim to be
like hey i want to do this or was it
like
how'd that come into the movie yeah no i
i
didn't call him maybe i should have but
i just remember at some point we had tom
flying up around
in the the city and one of my favorite
movies
uh you know of all time was that
original batman just i remember this the
nostalgia i remember standing in line
being around the corner and to give
homage to that especially also being at
warner brothers i felt like oh we should
be able to pull this off
and i just wanted to give homage to um
some artists that i know of and tim
burton being one of them that
if i did this those that get it would
get it
i was one of those people uh i would
imagine that something like this and you
bring up roger rabbit
everything has to be very meticulously
planned out when you're doing a tom and
jerry movie because
you know you have live action with uh
animated characters
how much did that sort of impact the
freedom that you sometimes have when
making a movie on set
where like you know someone might come
up with an idea but like you know you
have so much planned out because you
gotta
you know i'm just curious that balance
yeah what's interesting is i found i
didn't really know when i was shooting
but as i got into post-production you
know i had never done
animation like this in in such a way
that it that it meant so much to the
story where you had main characters that
were animated
i actually found that in post i had more
freedom than i remember
you know it's you know i'm so used to
coming to set and dealing with actors
who
come with certain choices and and you
kind of depend on them to bring those
choices
here i was at times going okay we've
plotted out this
but if a character came up with an idea
one thing that i am
i i've always had a rule that if you
have a better idea well let's use yours
and so these actors would sometimes
throw things out there mike was really
good at ad living stuff and chloe as
well
and when they threw something out we
just made sure that the animation
matched
what they did and they kind of worked
out a several times in the movie
uh are there any easter eggs that people
should look out for
uh in the film uh we do
men you know we do show you a couple of
characters in this tom and jerry world
there's
like i'm not giving away any story
points but there's goldie the gold you
know the goldfish that was in mini
and we also have droopy inside of the uh
inside of the
who was in the tom and jerry universe
that we kind of
winked to as well as other characters
that were also in the cartoons with tom
and jerry like butch
um so we had a lot of fun bringing those
characters uh kind of back to life and
and showing you who they were on that
note i got to stop i'm just going to say
congrats
and uh uh hopefully you know gotcha man
will happen at some point
yeah we both hope thanks my man exactly